in the video on triangle medians and
centroids i did essentially the proof
that the centroid is two-thirds along
the way of a median i did it using a
two-dimensional triangle in three
dimensions and i mentioned that i
thought at least it made the math a
little simpler but someone mentioned
that they'd be interested in seeing the
two-dimensional version of the proof so
so why not do that so let's just draw an
arbitrary triangle and i'll make one
i'll make one side of the triangle right
along the x-axis just to make
i think it'll make the math a little bit
easier maybe there's easier ways of
doing it so that's one side of the
triangle
that's the other side of the triangle
and let's put
let's put kind of the height of the
triangle the height of the triangle
let's put it on the y-axis so let's put
the so this triangle right here this is
the y-axis
that is the y-axis and then this right
here
this right here
is our
x-axis
now we said that this is an arbitrary
triangle so let's just make
just let's just make this distance equal
to
a so this point right here this vertex
would be the point a
comma zero so that distance is a
let's make this distance
let's make this distance right here be
equal to and let's make it equal to b so
this is the point
negative b comma zero
and then
let's make this distance this is the
point y is equal to c so this is a point
zero
comma c so it's an arbitrary triangle
any triangle can be represented this way
now let's think about its medians let's
think about its medians and the centroid
and i'm only going to do for two of the
medians because we know that the third
median will also intersect at the same
centroid so let's just find so we have a
median on this we have a a midpoint i
should say on this side of the triangle
and its coordinates are just going to be
the midpoint of those two points or
0 plus a over 2 which would just be a
over 2 and then c plus 0 over 2 which
would just be c over 2. let's do the
same thing over here the midpoint of
this side right over here is going to be
negative b plus zero over two so it's
negative b over two and then zero plus c
over two so it's just going to be
it's just going to be
c over 2.
now that we know all the coordinates for
the vertices and the midpoints at least
of these two sides we can find the
equations for the lines that the medians
are part of so we could find the
equation for this line
we could find the equation for this line
in purple then we can find the equation
for the other line that connects these
two dots find their intersection and
we'll essentially have the coordinates
of our centroid of the intersection of
the medians and we could do it for this
one too but that would be redundant
because it's going to intersect in the
same point
so what would be what would be the
equation for this line right over here
well our slope
our slope is going to be change in y so
c over 2 minus 0 so that's just c over 2
over change in x so a over 2
minus
minus b
minus b so it's minus negative b i
should say so it's plus b i could write
a plus b over here but just to make the
math simple i'll write plus 2b
plus 2b over 2. right i just subtracted
a negative b which is the same thing as
adding a b and i just and adding a b is
the same thing as adding a 2b over 2.
and i did that so these have the same
these have the same denominator i could
add them or i could just multiply the
numerator and denominator both by 2 and
i'll get the slope is equal to c over
a plus
2b so that's the slope of this line
right over here and then we know some
points here we could just use the point
slope formula for the equation of a line
we know the point negative b comma 0 is
on the line so we know that the equation
of this line in purple let me stay in
the purple is going to be
y minus 0
is equal to
is equal to x minus negative b or i
could say x plus b
times our slope times c
over
a plus 2 b a plus 2b
and obviously this would just simplify
to y is equal to all of this business
over here so this is essentially the
equation of this median right here if
the line just kept going or this line
the median is a line segment that is
part of this line now let's do the same
thing for
let us do the same thing for this line
right over here this median right over
here so once again its slope is change
over change in y over change in x so the
change in y c over two minus zero so the
slope here is equal to c over two minus
zero which is just c over 2
over negative b over 2
negative b over 2 minus a or i could say
minus 2 a over 2. that's the same thing
as minus a and do the same thing
multiply the numerator and the
denominator by two we get c over
c over
negative b minus
negative b
minus two a so the equation of this line
right here the other median
the equation of this other median right
over here is well we have this point
over here so we could use the point
slope again we get y minus 0
y minus 0 is equal to x minus a is equal
to x minus a
times the slope times c
over
negative b minus
negative b minus 2a so we have the two
equations for these lines we can now use
that information to find their
intersection which is going to be the
centroid well to do that we have both of
these in terms of y right y minus 0 is
the same thing as y y minus 0 is the
same thing as y so we could just set
this
as being equal
to that so let's do that we get
x
plus b
times c
over
a
plus 2 b
is equal to
x minus a times c
over
negative b minus 2a well both sides are
divisible by c we can assume that their
c is non-zero so this triangle actually
exists it actually exists in two
dimensions so we can divide both sides
by c and we get that let's see now we
can cross multiply
we can multiply
x plus b times this quantity right here
and that's going to be equal to a plus
2b times this quantity over here
and so we can just distribute it so it's
going to be x times all of this business
so it's going to be x
times negative b minus 2a
plus b times all of this so that's going
to be minus b squared minus 2 a b so i
just multiply that times that is going
to be equal to this times that so it's
going to be x times all of this business
x times a plus
2b
minus a times that so minus distribute
to a minus
a squared minus 2 a b
see if we can simplify this so we have a
negative 2 a b on both sides so let's
just subtract that out and then if we
let's
so we cancel things out let's subtract
this from both sides of the equation so
we'll have a minus
minus x times a plus 2b
do and i'll subtract that from here but
i'll write it a little different it'll
simplify things so this will become
this will become a
x times i'll distribute the negative
inside the a plus 2b
so negative a minus
2b
and let's add a b squared to both sides
so plus b squared
plus b squared i want to collect all the
x terms on one side and all the
constants on the other
and so this becomes
this becomes
on the left hand side the coefficient on
x i have negative b minus 2b is negative
3b
my negative 2a minus a is negative 3
a
times x
is equal to these guys cancel out these
guys cancel out is equal to b squared
minus a squared is equal to b squared
minus a squared let's see if we can
factor this already looks a little
suspicious and in a good way something
that we should be able to solve this can
be factored we could factor out a
negative three or actually factor out a
three we'll get three times b minus
a
three times
let me
actually let's factor out a negative 3.
so negative 3
negative 3 times b plus a
times x is equal to now this is the same
thing as b plus a
times b minus a
so we can divide both sides by b plus a
divide both sides by b plus a and we
have negative 3 times x is equal to b
minus a well let's just divide both
sides by negative 3. we get x is equal
to
b minus a
over negative 3 which is the same thing
as
a
minus b
a minus b over 3. so we have the x
coordinate we have the x coordinate so
far for our centroid it is a minus b
over three
it is
a minus b over three and you kind of see
hints of the solution over here a minus
b is this entire distance it's one third
of this entire distance although i don't
want to jump the gun too much because it
complicates it just thinking about just
the x coordinate but let's figure out
the y coordinate to do that we can just
substitute back into one of these
equations up here this was the this was
the equation of this median the gray
median that we had done so let's
substitute back in we have y is equal to
y i'll do it over here y is equal to x
minus a times c x is this thing over
here so it's a minus b
over 3
minus a
so i'm going to subtract instead of just
writing a minus a over here i'm going to
write a a negative 3 over 3. so minus 3
a
over 3. that's this minus a right over
here i just multiplied it and divided it
by 3. it's going to be all of that times
c
over
negative b minus 2a so this is going to
be equal to see in the numerator up here
we have an a minus 3a so this is equal
to negative b
negative
b
we have a negative b there and then we
have a a minus 3a is minus 2a so this
becomes negative b minus 2a
times we could factor out the 1 3 times
c over 3. so that's what the numerator
is all of that over negative b minus 2a
well that's going to cancel with that
and so our y coordinate is going to be
equal to c over 3.
so our y coordinate over here is c
over 3. now we could just use the
distance formula now we know all the
coordinates and you feel free to do it
if you like but there's a slight
simplification or at least in my mind a
slight simplification we know
we know that the height
we know that the y-coordinate
we know that the y-coordinate of
the centroid is c over three so this
right here this point over here is c
over three so we could actually use
maybe an easier argument because
remember our whole point was to show our
whole point was to show that this point
is two-thirds or two-thirds along the
median away from the vertex so let me
draw this vertex now here our whole
point of this video is we said this is
the midpoint of this side over here is
to show that this
this right here is two-thirds along the
way or that this length is twice this
length or that this length
this length is two-thirds of the entire
length of the median so how can we do
that well the simplest way i can do that
and you can actually you could actually
just use the coordinates and use the
distance formula but a simpler way just
the way that we've arranged this is just
to use an argument of similar triangles
because this right here
this right here is
we know that this entire height right
here in blue is c
we know this entire height over here in
blue is c
we know that we know that this height
right over here is c over three
or you could view that as one third
times c and so we know that this height
we know that this height over here
we know that that distance is two-thirds
is two-thirds c so we can use a similar
triangle argument let's say
let's say that this entire thing right
here is the length of the median and
let's just call that i don't know let's
call that l and let's say we want to
figure out how far along the median away
from the vertex that is and let's just
call that i don't let me use another
another
let me just call that distance right
over let me do this in a different color
let's call
let's call this distance right over here
let's see i've already used a b's and
c's let's call that d
so if if we can show that the ratio of d
to l is two thirds if this is two thirds
of the distance then we're done and we
can use that by similar triangles we
have two similar triangles we have this
let me use a new color
we have this triangle
which is kind of embedded inside of this
larger triangle right over here they
both share the same vertex this angle
over here they both have right angles
over here and since they have two of the
same angles their third angle has to be
the same so they're definitely similar
triangles so we can just set up a ratio
here two-thirds c which is this length
right over here
two that's the that's just kind of the
the vertical side of the smaller
triangles we could write two-thirds c
over this entire length over the length
of the larger that's the this
corresponding side of the larger similar
triangle over c
is equal to
is equal to the hypotenuse of the
smaller similar triangle
d over the hypotenuse of the longer of
the longer similar triangle or the
bigger similar triangle d over l well
this is clearly just divide the
numerator and denominator by c this
clearly becomes two-thirds so the ratio
from of this of this of this length to
this larger length is two-thirds or this
is two-thirds a long way along the
median away from the vertex so there you
go that's the two-dimensional proof that
the centroid is two-thirds along the way
of any median from the vertex or
one-third along the way along the median
or one-third the distance of the median
from the opposite midpoint anyway
hopefully you enjoyed that